there he is
leave Hollywood heartthrob sex symbol
glamour sexiest man in the world
Wow who could've yes who could have
guessed looking at this
I should probably smile with teeth no
have you had a mouse reduction since
then it's most of you look like a hinged
person it's a lot like I was a pretty
cool kid in high school too how old are
you they're not probably two years ago
you had the thing that a lot of people I
think I have that embarrassment of that
their parent is a teacher in the school
but you took that embarrassment and you
took it to a different level with your
mom as a teacher yeah I had my mom for
personal development slash sex education
that's terrible you should have been
excused that class learnt a lot learnt a
lot now that I remember it coming up and
they're like yeah you're gonna have your
mom for sex sex education and then the
first class we had together she handed
out these these cards to everyone that
had some form of sexually transmitted
disease and for whatever reason she felt
the need to pick me first and stand up
and she said Liam what do you have and I
said well mum I have chlamydia
thanks for this this is awesome
I know new episode of Graham Thursdays
at 11:30 get caught up full episodes
available on BBC America common on
demand
you